[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Philly sit let's do this
when I put up you know
good to see you filly first of all
before we get this started the amount of
gratitude that I have for this city for
beating the [ __ ] Patriots in the
Super Bowl let's [ __ ] go thank you
for that man I hate those [ __ ]
today's an extremely special day for me
because today is my mother's birthday
and and I thought I would use that as a
framework of the opening dialogue giving
a sense of who's speaking today I won't
go too much into mindset and motivation
and those kind of things because I think
we have a lot of people covering it I'm
actually gonna go pretty practical on
the back end half of this about why I
think most of you are massively missing
the mark and I include myself in that
that we're missing the mark in this
enormous gold rush of Facebook ads and
Instagram ads LinkedIn YouTube no matter
how much content you're producing for
whatever you're trying to achieve
whether it has to raise money for the
PTA or sell sneakers or build your real
estate firm or whatever you do the one
thing for all the people here in the
front and all those homies that I love
so much in the back
man it takes a while for noise to get
the [ __ ] up here sit is crazy the one
thing I know for a fact that connects
every person here that the cameraman
right there myself you all of you is
that attention is the asset that before
you can tell me how great you are why I
should buy your thing why I should do
the thing that you want me to do vote
for me buy my thing do this help that
that attention is the asset and I have
spent the last 20 years of my business
career becoming a practitioner in what I
call under priced attention whether it
was email or websites or Google AdWords
or YouTube or Facebook or Twitter the
reason I have the great luxury of
standing up here at least for the merit
of what I've been able to accomplish in
my professional career is I've been able
to execute within real estate that has
been under priced by the market I've
been able to storytellin execute in
there and that has led to the results
that I have as I got older I got smarter
and started and investing in the
platforms that became the most important
real estate and those are the
foundations of the things that ended and
when I buy the New York Jets and win my
Super Bowls it will 100% be on the back
of the things that I'm going to talk to
you on the second half which is how all
of you need to start buying and creating
on these platforms and why so many of
you have failed how many people here by
show of hands have run Facebook or
Instagram ads and it hasn't worked
because I think it's a lot of people
raise them high there's a very specific
reason it's because it's not that easy
it's not just you know it's like me
saying I'm gonna put a ball in the hoop
like that's great but that doesn't mean
I'm gonna be a professional basketball
player it takes a skill set and I'll get
into that and and that's the thing if
you want to ask me what I'm trying to
accomplish here today every person in
here is under spending and under
creating on
LinkedIn YouTube Twitter podcasting
email everybody me too and I'm have 22
full-time people I'm spending 3 or 4
million dollars a year between
advertising dollars and people and I'm
under doing it so I really need to
deliver that that's part two part one is
a little bit more interesting to me over
the last year it's become obvious to me
that optimism is actually a strategy
that I'm fascinated by what I was gifted
I was gifted through my mom's DNA and by
the way that she parented me to be
fundamentally in a place where I just am
incapable of seeing the negative I don't
really it's not that I'm delusional ah
basically my life for the last 15 27
years has been pretty basic if I wake up
and me and the 7 or 8 people that I love
the most didn't die I'm [ __ ] pumped
now I I really really need you to
understand what I'm saying
I mean it it's super basic I have a
happy life not because of my success
seeing my dear highschool friend Jess
right there in 1 to 3 in the 5th row
it was super fun I ran to her in the
hotel last night and and I was there
with her her husband a friend and and it
was fun for me it was emotional for me
because she's one of a very you know we
only went to high school at 250 for kids
I know it's 254 in our class now I don't
know how many of you follow me on
Instagram but the happiest day I've had
in the last month was when I posted my
report card a month ago because I was
ranked 243 out of 254 in my high school
but there's not a lot of people because
I was very insular what she can tell you
is that for the first 3 and 7/8 year of
my high school career because I worked
in my dad's liquor store and because I
worked after school I didn't do
after-school sports I didn't hang out I
didn't have much of a social life
I saw baseball cards in the malls of New
Jersey and I worked in my dad's store I
was in my own [ __ ] and so for me it's
fun to see her right here because you
could say you know I have empathy one
could say well you're happy because
you've made it I was [ __ ] super happy
when I wasn't making it and doing the
[ __ ] that nobody wanted to do you know a
lot of people are very confused with my
narrative when people want to troll me
they're like easy for you you were
handed three million dollars or this
that the other thing I spent the first
12 years of my career 15 hours a day
paying myself less than $100,000 a year
every year building my family liquor
store business for my parents
I left at 34 years old with zero equity
in wine library no money to my name and
no equity on paper I basically started
over seven years ago but I checked
thanks dad but I checked
but I checked a very important box for
me I don't know how many of you are
immigrants or the children of immigrants
or how many of you are in the same way
that I am that have the great great
fortune to have their parents be their
heroes but there is no greater feeling
in life than feeling that you've settled
the score with your parents and gave
them as much as they gave you and that
feels incredible for me of what I did in
the first part of my career but here's
what I will tell you on my mom's
birthday my mom did some crazy ass
parenting on me first of all the number
one thing that my mom did for me and the
number one issue for the far majority of
this room and I'm just lucky of good
parenting in DNA I don't think I'm
better than you I'm just telling you
because I see it every day and because
I've read a lot of tweets in the last 24
hours of people that are in this
audience and I look at not just a tweet
that you said you're excited to see me I
look at all the [ __ ] you post cuz I'm
trying to get a sense of you [ __ ] the
number one gift my mom gave me is a lack
of entitlement if you want to talk for
all the good [ __ ] that's going on with
me I literally think I mean nothing I'm
being dead serious with you I I think
I'm the greatest of all time with my
confidence of bravado and ego and
excitement and the things I see are
happening but I equally know that when I
did if I disappear tomorrow cool I'd
have a good social media day and then
everybody would I'm telling you when
Prince and David Bowie died in that
little window and I watched those icons
of culture get about 24 hours of love
and then everybody forgot I was like
[ __ ] right I mean I mean it and so
what's really empowering and what's
holding so many people back here is
entitlement you feel like somebody owes
you something because something went
wrong somewhere along the way I don't
I actually think whatever went wrong for
you is the best [ __ ] that ever happened
to you because adversity is absolutely
the foundation of success
the the other thing I know is I have bad
news nobody gives a [ __ ] about your
problems and this is super important to
understand the second you actually
understand that nobody actually gives a
[ __ ] the only people that listen to you
complaining are your loser [ __ ]
friends if you like complaining like
just take a step back look around the
next time you're complaining about the
government or or you know racial or
feminine or but yeah I've heard I had a
guy sit in front of me the other day
crying that his life was bad cuz he was
a white male rich white male I was like
oh [ __ ] we've gone everywhere now you're
either on the offense or defense I just
want you to know something one of the
things that's been really on my mind is
I think a lot of people think they're in
the middle they're like in a transit
you're only on the offense or the
defense and I've realized that I've been
on the offense my whole life because I
never felt entitled to anything an
incredible thing happens when you're
born with very little you know I was
born in the Soviet Union we come to
America I live in a studio apartment in
Queens you know my parents bought me six
toys in my entire life kind of thing we
took one one family vacation in my
entire life
right when I want a Nintendo my mom
looked me dead in the face and said good
go buy it and that was huge on the flip
side what she also did was she instilled
she let me rephrase she reinforced
things that came natural to me and made
them the most important things while I
was getting D's and F's and every other
immigrant parent was making their kids
get A's and B's because they thought
that's what mattered my mom was
accelerating and going out of her mind
anytime that I showed compassion anytime
that I showed empathy anytime that I
showed gratitude I want to opened a door
for a woman this is an amazingly
interesting story to me
I remember after losing a little league
baseball game which I'm extremely
petted him so basically if I lost in
anything from the ages of 5 to 13 I
cried on the spot like some straight
[ __ ] real tears [ __ ] right so we had
a devastating loss in a little league
baseball game that we lost I mean I
remember we lost to the Cougars 3:2 to
those [ __ ] anyway we went to
McDonald's cuz my mom my mom didn't like
buying [ __ ] but she knew I was super sad
so she's gonna buy me a [ __ ] Big Mac
so we went to McDonald's we got there
and I will remember this for the rest of
my life I hope I was eight I opened a
door for a woman just walk-in just open
the door for a woman you would have
thought that I won a Nobel Peace Prize
my mom made such a big deal about that
you know there's a legendary story for
my mom of when on my 10th birthday we
went to Toys R Us and because Cabbage
Patch Kids were so hard to get they had
him so I took all my money and bought my
sister the Kabat ratchet on my birthday
she and that's enough that was a good
one that's better than the door but
still you have to understand what she
did and honestly for all of you that
watch me it's what I'm doing for my
community with my content we my friends
more than ever now we need to focus on
the truth here's the truth this second
that we're sitting here is the greatest
second in the history of mankind for
human beings this is math no matter what
you have going on your grandparents had
it worse we are so good at blaming other
things and dwelling and complaining on
[ __ ] without looking at the reality of
the situation no matter how bad you have
it millions billions have it worse and
so for me the mindset that I've rolled
in this whole game
is nobody cares nobody cares and not
that they don't care people have
compassion but they can't think about
how much you can care even for the
people you love the most it's just a
human thing and more importantly we have
it ridiculously good this internet thing
this internet thing is the most
important invention in the history of
the human being all the things that you
worry about of like the man stopping you
or something stopping you all these
things that we envision that are the
reasons why you haven't been successful
this internet thing is taking away the
Internet
the Internet is the middleman it's true
you have to understand how ridiculous
this thing is the ability for you to
create content pictures videos and
written words on Facebook YouTube
Instagram LinkedIn Beyond and going
direct to the audience eliminates any
excuse you come up with
I could literally spend the next month
one by one systematically going through
this big room and no matter what excuse
you come up with the answer is gonna be
and guys we have to eliminate
complaining and dwelling we have to the
like it's just everything and that's
what she did for me she instilled the
right positive things and most of all
she eliminated [ __ ] excuses she
eliminated entitlement and most of all
how many people are parents in here she
did one other thing that's super
important to me this whole fifth place
trophies [ __ ]
I have two kids I get it you love your
kids so much I get it but what we have
manifested into we are such pieces of
[ __ ] but we have manifested into in over
protecting our kids and manipulating
adversity and creating a world where
there isn't winning and losing is the
reason I hate I hate when I hang out
with like a 48 or 57 year old homie and
and he'll be like Gary these [ __ ]
Millennials I'm like you [ __ ] raised
the Millennial you dick
like like all the 40 50 year olds all of
us 38 40 you know every one of us with
15 year olds enough we love [ __ ] on
these kids they're soft they're entitled
we made them entitled like like we have
to get back to winning and losing
you have to stop coddling your kids of
course of course they are struggling
when you actually thought until the age
of 14 that you won everything when you
lost you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
the Patriots lost I knew that would work
I think everybody I think generally
believe look I'm gonna get very real
with you if you decided to spend money
to come here for this lineup entitlement
is a big problem that you have in some
shape or form I'm being dead [ __ ]
serious
not everybody I don't know all of you
but I'm telling you right now that 80 to
90% of you I'm being very very frank and
I'm coming
i'm not razzing i'm coming from an
incredibly important place right now
please eliminate entitlement nobody
nothing nothing nobody owes you [ __ ]
nobody gives a [ __ ] that your parents
are alcoholics nobody [ __ ] cares that
you were born to a tough family and
here's the truth if you actually live
that if you actually live that whether
it's true or not you can then finally
navigate all of you are looking
backwards and people are [ __ ] passing
you by yesterday's [ __ ] over and i'm
telling you right now that to me over
the last decade has been stunning to me
people's ability to dwell and think
about circumstances that they had no
control over that are now dictating how
they go forward is [ __ ] cancer and if
I can [ __ ] strangle it out of your
[ __ ] body here right now Philadelphia
I would because there's no tactic I'm
gonna teach you there's nothing
motivational me or less or [ __ ] Tony
are gonna say to you that's gonna do
dick for you if you're still dwelling
that you're [ __ ] aunt stole eight
hundred dollars from you like people
just woman laughing I'm laughing too
like [ __ ] like people emailing
garyvee like I totally be crushing it
but my girlfriend cheated on me in
nineteen eighty five I'm like you're a
[ __ ] loser dick laughs like what
while you guys were watching MTV what
the [ __ ] the matter with you
people complain that Facebook and
instagrams algorithm changed and they're
not getting as many likes
it's free I get 1000 emails and dm's a
day from people who say to me Gary Vee
sucks [ __ ] me instagrams
what the [ __ ] is instagram doing they're
killing me they changed the algorithm
YouTube - and Google before that in 2003
these are [ __ ] free platforms and
you're literally complaining about the
algorithm change let me tell you why
you're getting less likes or getting
hurt by the algorithm change cuz your
contents not good enough because you
joined engagement groups and you each
like each other [ __ ] you [ __ ] hacking
piece of [ __ ] oh there we go
oh you're mad at Instagram because you
and a [ __ ] bunch of Pakistani hackers
decided to get into a group and like
each other's [ __ ] and now you're not
getting as much engagement do you think
[ __ ] sucks is an idiot
my friends the lack of patience in the
system right now is extraordinary
we have 22 year old life coaches on
Instagram
I don't want to get side rails cuz this
could get real [ __ ] ugly filly when I
was 28 years old six years out of school
a lot of geof's and i's friends first
started getting facebook because that's
the time it started coming out I because
I worked every [ __ ] minute what she
can tell you is literally basically we
threw our caps in the air for graduation
and I disappeared off the face of the
[ __ ] earth because I worked every
[ __ ] minute this was the first time I
reconnected with a bunch of my friends
cuz here was Facebook and it was awesome
it was like digital like you know class
reunion [ __ ] it was amazing for a lot of
us were part of that generation as I
connected with in it was really
interesting in a very nice way because
we came from a really nice place most of
my high school friends basically
basically in some shape or form 10 or 12
of them said oh you still work at your
dad's liquor store and I remember that
fear is super well because I'm really
desperately trying to put patients on a
pedestal as a good thing because it is a
good thing because the game is long and
so many people here are walking around
with insecurities and all their behavior
of what they want is to just prove to
somebody else that they've made it
literally people buy dumb [ __ ] like
supreme bags so that they could look
cool in front of their people literally
people buy seven bedroom homes seven
bedroom guys nobody uses their
seven-bedroom home we live in four rooms
but it's status they [ __ ] lease cars
to look the part they wear clothes to
look the part they buy homes to look the
part
all all because they live their lives on
defense you live your life on defense
because you worry about other people's
points of view the end back cuz just as
here that's just so fun cuz I get to use
stories that
freshman year of high school pretty
interesting year right because you got
to kind of reestablish your brand [ __ ]
gets really gnarly freshman year vice
gone while jess was being super popular
her freshman year of high school let me
tell you what I was doing I was walking
around the lunchroom trying to sell
baseball cards to everybody sitting at a
table not necessarily the move to make
yourself the most popular person in a
world where that's what matters I'm
telling you that story for one reason
because of great parenting on my mom's
birthday she put me in a place very
early on that there was only one voice
in my game my own as a matter of fact
it's so scary to me how singular my own
voice is it doesn't mean that I don't
listen to feedback it doesn't mean that
I'm delusional and I think I can get
away with bad [ __ ] and it's all okay it
just means that I am incapable of
valuing anybody else's opinion including
my mom's my wife's and my children's
opinion about me over my own it's super
important if you really listen to where
I'm going with this talk if you realized
how much of the actions you do is to
show your mom or your dad or your
sibling or your spouse or somebody show
somebody else that you made it or you
did it it is remarkably scary how many
people are dictated by somebody else's
opinion when you layer patients into it
it's good to have a chip in your
shoulder I've got a lot but patients too
many people struggle with being booed in
the third quarter
too many people if you're how many
people under 30 you guys are still
playing the [ __ ] national anthem
too many people rushing taking shortcuts
doing dumb [ __ ] because they want to win
in the first quarter this is a long game
my friends sure you can get hit by bus
great I understand for the far majority
of us this is a long game and what the
way medicine is going now how many
people here between 40 and 60 raise your
hands this is where it gets real
interesting for us we're just gonna live
a lot longer than we thought I mean it
like how many people are 40 or 40 to 50
real quick do you remember how old you
thought 40 to 50 was when you were 26
when I first centered in my dad's liquor
store my cousin Bobby was 30 I was 22 I
thought he was old as [ __ ] now sitting
up here at 42 when I look at this little
man here how old are you my man 9
I feel 92 like literally right that's
the crazy [ __ ] that they don't tell us
for all the 20 to 30 year olds in here
what they don't tell you is you're gonna
feel basically the same in 20 years
you're gonna have just as much fire and
there's plenty of 60 year olds in here
who have just as much fire it actually
doesn't change as much as you think
especially not here right maybe you're a
little slower maybe the back there's
some of that [ __ ] but not here not here
and the quicker you understand that the
quicker you won't look for a fast buck
do you know many of my friends my
community that when I post on Instagram
I mean this is what the hypocrisy the
[ __ ] hypocrisy do you know many times
I watch [ __ ] for all my talking I'm a
listener i watch [ __ ] don't leave a
comment on my Instagram and think I'm
not watching I posted something about
patience a year ago and everybody comes
in you know a lot of keyboard warriors
out there these days everybody loves to
look the part on social media but what
are your [ __ ] actions is what I'm
interested in so I'll post something
about patience and comments will Kareem
be like yeah Gary Vee patience this and
that literally it hit me because
somebody had a funny username and then
that email had it I have a great memory
and I kind of look back
a kid who wrote a [ __ ] manifesto of
how I changed his life on imposing
patience right how it was the greatest
thing and I taught him and I'm the
father he never had which kind of pissed
me off cuz I'm not that old but is the
same kid that nine months later after
that post sent me an email crying asking
me for help asking to borrow money which
didn't bother me but it speaks to the
desperation because I don't know him
because he maxed all his credit cards
out to buy Bitcoin and Bitcoin went down
people are chasing do you know how many
of my homies that I grew up with that
were social media experts now say in
their bio that their cryptocurrency
experts who are also real estate experts
people are [ __ ] experts people are
chasing the collective answers to this
room are way more patience take your
entitlement and leave it in the [ __ ]
garbage nobody gives a [ __ ]
period and the fundamental thing that
really matters nobody you've ever met
has succeeded in building anything
without working their [ __ ] face/off
I literally throw up in my [ __ ] mouth
every time I hear the word pass a
[ __ ] income
it's my truth there's nothing [ __ ]
passive about income my friends
there's no [ __ ] system you're not
gonna be [ __ ] smoking weed in a
[ __ ] island in Jamaica while other
idiots are working for you you [ __ ]
idiot and so I highly recommend as you
sit in your [ __ ] chair right now that
you start getting real with yourself
every excuse that you have it's your
[ __ ] fault
don't lend your aunt money [ __ ] all
right that's my framework it's work its
patience it's a long game you've got to
put in the effort every single day I
highly recommend finding something that
comes natural or you like too many
people do [ __ ] they don't like for the
money to buy [ __ ] that doesn't matter
it's the most basic [ __ ] on earth how
many of you are so miserable right now
but if you made $30,000 less if you
could afford it and all you have to do
is sell your home and go live in an
apartment like it's crazy to me the
traps that people are putting themselves
into for buying [ __ ]
by the way buying [ __ ] to impress other
people you're playing for an outside
game now let me tell you how I think you
do it that's the framework let's get the
details content content a video a
written word or a picture content is the
gateway drug to every single thing in
our society anything that you want to
happen you want to sell sneakers you
want people to buy your course you want
to sell homes I don't give a [ __ ] no
matter what you do in this room content
is the gateway drug to your success if
you are not producing pictures videos
and written words for Facebook Twitter
Instagram snapchat LinkedIn YouTube
medium if you are not doing that you
were fundamentally irrelevant in society
I don't give a [ __ ] that you didn't grow
up with it I don't give a [ __ ] that you
hate going to a restaurant and seeing
two people on the phone and it's sad I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] if
you're judging your grandkids
they're so introverted now they don't
know how to communicate they don't look
in your eye
[ __ ] you grandpa this is the new game
[Applause]
you could be sad all you want you're the
same [ __ ] that said you would never
get a cellphone and now you have one
barry technology doesn't give a [ __ ]
about how we grew up technology is going
to do its thing technology doesn't care
what your opinion is too many people
here have an opinion about society and
then use that to dictate their business
careers that is the most insane [ __ ] of
all time
your romantic point of view on how it
should be is the reason that you're not
moving forward in your business career
you in one side of your mouth think that
Facebook is ruining our democracy and in
the other side don't think it works to
sell your dumb [ __ ] we have to take a
collective step back here right now
Philly and understand one thing this is
the remote control of our lives
let me say something very simple I'm
gonna demonstrate it to you and it's if
you really understand what I'm saying
right now it's gonna really matter
Facebook and Instagram our streams right
there's only so much real estate
Facebook's and instagrams only asset in
society is your attention
the reason the algorithm is the way that
it is is because if they keep showing
you dumb [ __ ] and you don't like it
you're gonna leave how many people here
have been on email for 15 years or
longer raise your hand
great remember how we used to read email
15 years ago we read it for all the
youngsters in here I had an email
newsletter in 1996 that had 91% open
rates everybody read it everybody asked
on it I sold a lot of wine but we just
kept sending email and so did everybody
else and you started to tune it out you
know why the algorithms not showing your
content as much because the people that
do see it aren't showing that they like
it thus it doesn't want to show it to
other people
the algorithm is saving ourselves from
ourselves the algorithm works it's why
it's working but here's the problem with
the algorithm there's only so many
pictures and videos and right now we're
just competing amongst ourselves
I'm the Alpha I'm the biggest invested
it's why I'm growing the fastest others
in here doing solid decent or nothing at
all and that is a direct correlation to
your success and more importantly your
future success here's the problem my
friends coca-cola and BMW and Comcast
and the Eagles and GE and the biggest
companies in the world haven't invested
properly into the feed yet the feed is
just one feed right now it costs eight
or nine dollars to get in front of a
thousand people soon it's going to cost
50 and 90 and 200 and you're gonna sit
and cry that you weren't doing more of
this just like I cry that I didn't spend
more money on Google AdWords from 2001
to 2004 when they were grossly
underpriced let me show you why I know
this Philly please do me a real honor
and stand up right now if Jesus [ __ ]
Christ
please stand up right now if besides
live sports you basically mainly now
watch Netflix HBO Go Hulu or anything
that's OTT if you're mainly watching
Netflix stand-up this is [ __ ] crazy
thank you bro everyone everybody look
around staying keep staying up I want
everybody's keep staying up look at this
room we can all agree these aren't
thirteen-year-old kids this is now a
good wide range of individuals and ages
we have switched to OTT you can sit
thank you
85% of this audience consumes this many
television commercials nobody here
watches television commercials Super
Bowl the best we all watch it every
other commercial the worst now let me
give you data 80 let me say it nice and
slow eighty billion dollars is spent in
the making and distributing of TV
commercials in America a year and all of
its going directly in the [ __ ]
garbage when Pepsi and Kellogg's and
Kraft and BMW finally feel the pain of
them throwing money directly in the
trash which is coming they will switch
it and it will come into this nice
little place known Facebook and
Instagram and everything else and right
now while you're sitting on your hands
and not spending every dollar you can't
afford to on running ads not organic not
you posting on your organic page no
running a hundred dollars with ads on a
one mile radius of your office or two
people that buy t-shirts or whatever it
may be
while you're sitting on your hands
you're watching the single greatest
marketing opportunity walk right by you
and everybody in this room including
myself will regret for not spending more
if I can leave here with anything if I
could leave here with anything it would
be to get you to understand how much of
a gold rush the underpriced attention on
Facebook and Instagram is and get you to
finally get off your [ __ ] ass and
Google how to run I love when people
like well Gary how do I run ads on
Facebook Google and Dick
how do I run ads on Facebook enter I
didn't grow up with it
neither did I you didn't grow up driving
you figured it out
the fact that you're willing to not put
in the 5 to 10 hours to understand it
for something that brings you so much
value is mind-boggling to me and then if
you understand that the fact that you're
not doing it and still debating boggles
my mind this is my listen to what I'm
doing this is a platform that goes up in
price if more people are on it
it is the single platform behind the
foundation of all my success and I'm
trying to get you to go into it at my
own expense because I'm competing with
you for that same real estate because it
is that good and I'm just putting it on
the record so I can run this exact video
in 8 years and when I'm talking about
something new it's gonna say remember in
2018 when you were in Philly and you
didn't listen to me
you [ __ ] up don't make that same
mistake with augmented reality or
virtual reality or AI or whatever [ __ ]
house I'm gonna be believing in in 9
years this is going to go away the same
way that Google AdWords did in the same
way that email went away it's not that
it goes away TV's not away radios not
away it's just not a great deal anymore
attention is the asset everything works
but what about the price I can run a lot
of television and people would know
about me but that would cost millions
instead of tens of thousands for the
same thing we as a collective have not
quantified how remarkable this is how
many people here sell something like
vitamins or t-shirts or sneakers or wine
raise your hand every one of you needs
to figure out influencer marketing you
should leave this [ __ ] conference
right now go home and start DMing people
on Instagram and asking them how much
money it costs for them to post a
picture holding up your [ __ ] and how
many people here have consumed my
content for a year or longer thank you
you know this is the same [ __ ] I got one
[ __ ] pitch
being serious my pitch is simple stop
buying dumb [ __ ] and start doing the
right thing and here's the right thing
it's very basic make pictures videos and
content for the social networks and the
platforms that people pay attention to
how many people here listen to my
podcast raise your hand how many people
since listening to my podcast now have
started watching a little less video
because you're listening on the podcast
raise your hand this is so interesting
to me everybody here if you have a
business of any sort or ambition needs
to figure out how to start a podcast
audio is passive you can listen while
you're driving you can listen while
you're traveling you can listen while
you're working out you can listen while
you're walking the dog
it doesn't make you do this you just got
those [ __ ] nice little ear pods the
ones that you said you would never wear
in your ears my friends something I
figured out about myself a very long
time ago I'm very good at knowing what
you're gonna do while you're telling me
that you're not gonna do it a lot of
people here said that they would never
have a Facebook account that they would
never be on snapchat a lot of people
here said they would never be on
internet dating a lot of people here
said yeah a lot of people here a lot of
people here said they would never have a
cell phone you're gonna do everything do
you understand why technology's more
powerful than your opinion it's true and
I have good news for you or bad news
depending on if you're an optimist or
pessimist most people are pessimists
it's just starting the robots are gonna
kill us
I'm not joking so since they're gonna
[ __ ] kill us wouldn't it be a good
idea to do the right thing while we're
here this is just starting book stores
came first then people that owned limo
companies everybody's on the record
the Internet's coming and it's gonna
take everything all of it there's the
internet vendors the companies that are
the first layer above the Internet
Google Facebook Apple Amazon and then
all of our jobs is to be the next layer
on top of that and the level of
disrespect that so many of you have for
these platforms and their capabilities
is the vulnerability of your upside if
you are not a practitioner you know many
people here have opinions on how
Facebook ad works but I've never run one
if you are not a practitioner I'm
producing not you hired your 24 year old
niece because she's young and she gets
this [ __ ] you if you are not a
practitioner of these six or seven
platforms on this phone 54% of time on
one report is spent on social networks
on all time spent on a cellphone
everybody's on a cell phone every minute
always watch your behavior this is
everybody makes excuses like well my
customers not on it or not yet or it's
coming this is here if you are not here
you do not exist
please stop judging it please stop being
romantic and most of all start being
honest with yourself the reason you have
those excuses is you don't want to put
in the work you do not want to put in
work or even worse you have a big ego
and you don't like the feeling of
starting with 19 followers or fans on
Instagram because you're worried about
what other people think about you not
having a big following cuz you're a big
shot in another world and you [ __ ]
[ __ ] pisses meet your [ __ ] ego
pisses me off
it it's your ego is your it's your
detriment you have ego because you think
somebody gives a [ __ ] about you
you know in in in really like summing
this up for me it's super simple
it it it's so easy and it's so hard it's
so hard because judgment and all these
things have been so grilled into your
mind it was your framework it was how
you were parented the environment it's
your it's your core but at some point
you've just got to realize that there's
only one game it's an inside game and
there's only one move it's called work
and and just the lack of execution the
enormous amount of ego the just all
these things are wrapping up into one
concoction that isn't working if you
have not had sustained growth it's
because normally you're impatient and
you're trying to move too fast right and
here's another thing and let me tell you
why I have a lot of passion for this
moment this to me since Google AdWords
is the greatest and early television ads
early cable early cable CNN MTV ESPN
they took advantage of early cable
that's why you know them still they
moved fast it's all the same game
attention is the framework here's what
scares me slash excites me the most it's
so great right now
how many people here are under 30 stand
up do it so let me tell you a couple
things about you for me one I'm so
pissed at all these old [ __ ] razzing
on you right you're welcome
but here's another thing I know about
you and honestly I genuinely believe
this is the best generation that ever
was when I look at the action see
although I really mean it I mean it
here's the one problem for everybody
who's standing up
you haven't been punched in the [ __ ]
mouth yet I need you to understand while
you stand here you've run your
professional career over the last eight
to ten years during only economic growth
all US other old [ __ ] that are
sitting down right now
we've been punched in the mouth we lived
professionally through 2007 and eight we
lived through 2001 and 97 and 96 of
course business is good and you can't
make money
posting a detox T on your Instagram or
you've got a [ __ ] brand because you
printed some words on a [ __ ] t-shirt
you dick you know course of course when
the economy is winning my friends and
you can sit thank you my friends who are
30 and under please be prepared for the
punch in the mouth please be prepared
when the biggest brick let me tell you
what happens when the [ __ ] [ __ ]
on Wall Street or cheating and the
economy collapses big brands stop
spending money
nobody's reaching out to you anymore
offering you 500 bucks for a picture you
don't get the leads it's nobody's
returning your calls people go into a
shell emotionally not just financially
and then you have to have something
nobody wants to give you money for your
[ __ ] we're the uber of dry cleaners
and every other [ __ ] stupid idea
running through everybody's [ __ ] head
right now I mean this I mean it
everybody's building apps and thinks
that it's worth four million dollars and
they're gonna raise a million dollars
from [ __ ] you know venture capital
they're gonna be [ __ ] Instagram my
friends for every one Instagram there's
eight trillion insta shits please
understand that we are living right this
day may 3rd 2018 the best [ __ ]
opportunity for entrepreneurs and people
ever stop listening to the [ __ ]
propaganda stop listening to the
[ __ ] propaganda of negativity that's
sold to you every fun
and a because they're trying to make
money fear sells don't get caught into
it
optimism is the gateway drug to
happiness period you either choose to
see it or you don't that's on you knock
yourself out
it's the facts it's the data we're
healthier better everything we got
nothing but problems you know what's
happened because of this internet thing
we've been exposed you know why it's so
you know how much I love [ __ ] me too
and all this stuff is the best because
we [ __ ] deserve it we're being
exposed big media hit it this is
exposing it this is it this is our
moment you will regret if you don't go
hard please stop being lazy and
egotistical or undereducated
or entitled go learn how to make
pictures audio video for Facebook
Instagram YouTube get the [ __ ] out of
this conference hall right now run home
and do [ __ ] thank you so much
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]